questions from the audience and like I
said keep it concise and let's get so
first question who's got a question all
right so the question is where's the
hardware in all of this like are we
lagging behind on the hardware side what
do you see coming around the corner Don
is in the restroom he should answer this
I think and I think I effectively
answered it here you go did you hear the
question it's about hardware one more
time one more time Liz the questioners
day 60 frames a second hardware when is
that coming is the question these 60
frames a second hardware for ps4 in just
in general ok well I mean you can hit
that now it's just really depends on
your application um so I mean it's there
you know you can boot up the FPS tracker
and actually see what you're doing and
you can certainly hit six FPS but yeah
I'm not really sure what we're getting
at here all right i'm going to add to
that I think Don already answered it
here's the thing any applicant any
application you write can run at one
frame per second I'm really good
hardware it's all about how you write
the software done spoke about it earlier
so yeah there's going to be some
sensitivities some devices are going to
run faster than others but in general I
think you need to perform its profile
for any device you're building for and
you can get 60 FPS on anything if you
build your application correctly all
right that's that next ten foot pole
anyway so yeah so the the question was
can you browse web GL content on the ps4
the answer is no not at this current
time don't look at me like that
I mean you know obviously it's you know
we want to enable more and more for our
browser at this current time you know we
we don't enable WebGL for just general
things on the web that could potentially
change at some point in the future but I
can't really say when or where or why
that would be the case so you know kind
of figure I get this question but you
know very much apologize for my evasive
answer their question is has there been
much acceptance of the GL TF format and
the general web community so far right
answer no but there's a good reason for
that which is we're really not promoting
it too much yet I talked about into my
talks Fabrice mentioned it in passing
it's a new format in fact we have not
even published the specification yet but
we're doing all the work out in the open
the spec itself is written in a JSON
schema that you can go look at there's
like zero pros like if you wanted to
torial I don't forget it you're going to
come talk to me and Fabrice or whatever
but it's all being done out in the open
where we're building prototypes out in
the open the Fabrice has got one on the
montage jeaious framework I've built one
on three J's that loads GL TF I showed
it to you tonight so all that stuff's
being done out in the open but the
Cronus group and this is a Cronus
project these are the people who made
the colada format and the WebGL standard
in fact are doing it as an RD project
that at some point we want to promote as
maybe a new standard essentially is the
the kind of format that you would do
with colada back in the day you get all
your data out of your modeling package
and into an application but this one for
the web we're going to do that someday
maybe this year but we did not want to
rush it we actually spoke about trying
to standardize this this year a game
developers conference coming up in March
we want to get the standard already and
get people using it and all that and
then Remy who's not here tonight Remy or
know who created colada said why don't
we get it right first a little bit more
get developers using it and then we'll
start promoting it and then we'll start
trying to standardize it so long story
short it's still a little bit early I am
having individual conversations with
lots of people who want to actually try
to build it into an application now but
we're talking about kind of a 0.8
version of the format so really not
cooked yet so that was question one well
we only have one question per person oh
there we go sorry Josh come back to that
one we have other come back go for it
yep uh I mean honestly I okay so he was
asking you know if I actually had more
time what exactly what I do further on
the ps4 um I mean I really felt as
though I hit all the things I kind of
wanted to hit in terms of the the whole
optimization thing you know obviously
there's a lot other people's code
involved because you know this was
basically a port I mean if I if I were
doing the whole thing me myself and I I
probably avoid JavaScript and probably
goes something like dart especially now
because you know at this point in time
it's better to think of javascript is
nothing more than assembly language and
used the tools and languages you
actually feel productive in so in that
sense I feel a whole hell of a lot more
productive in dart and I did kind of
want to go that route but didn't why add
any additional overhead because I was
interfacing with a bunch of JavaScript
code ok so the demo I showed earlier the
Unreal Engine demo was done with this
technology called M scripting Emscripten
takes code that has been compiled by a C
compiler or C++ compiler into what they
call intermediate code it's basically
byte codes that ultimately get turned
into machine language by the time the
executable has been linked so if you're
building something for Windows or the
Mac you'll use the c compiler and
ultimately you'll get Machine Co but it
goes through this thing called llvm an
intermediate code m script and takes
that llvm and somehow miraculously turns
it into JavaScript that can be executed
in your web browser the tool was built
at Mozilla the Firefox folks and they
actually done a bunch of different ports
and projects with it the most notable
one being this Unreal Engine level I
showed you they did this in a week I'm
sure this was a week of like five people
on each team from Mozilla and and unreal
you know epic games I'm not you know I
don't have the details on that but I'm
guessing I mean because it's pretty
involved I am now currently working on
an M scripting project myself so I could
tell you firsthand I went back and did
something I haven't done it didn't think
I would do for years which was get a
windows machine I I'm even running
Windows 8 I won't say anymore I got a
C++ compiler that was okay I mean it's
been a few years but i did it i compiled
stuff and then I ran the same scripting
tool on it and it actually is working
and I've spent about two weeks on this
project i'm on i can't say what it is
and it's not well documented my biggest
complaint if anything is the tool seemed
to work but you got to spend a lot of
time kind of trying to intuit what's
going on but what i showed you that 60
frames a second will 30 on my machine
but i've seen running on 60 on some
higher and hardware does a great job I
mean we're getting this really great
frame rate from something that if you
think about it I don't know if you know
unreal the app itself the games are
built in a scripting language so we not
only have C++ code compiled into
JavaScript that JavaScript itself is
running a language interpreter for
unreal script which the game was written
in so we have a cross compiled
application that's got an embedded
scripting language interpreter running
in it and defending you guys know what
interpreters are you know that's a big
deal and that was I mean you saw it
yourself that was kind of amazing so
long story short is M scripting is great
but you've got to suffer through a lot
of lack of documentation and Google's
your friend on that one I mean there's
there's a lot of people out there who've
suffered through the same problems as
you and that's what I've been doing this
week so there you go okay so me coming
from the real-time communications aspect
I think no
yeah time time yes so the first question
the question was what is the question
that I should be asking a year from now
well what are the what are the challenge
is going forward right so one of the
biggest types these days is connected
devices right this is where real time
communication plays an absolutely
critical role how it's how it's all done
how it's all managed we have these
gazillions of devices out there another
absolutely critical question in this
space is security once you open up your
home you open up your health you open up
basically your personal stuff that's
going to be absolutely crucial and then
the question is what happens when things
just don't work like you are on a subway
or you are you're on an airplane these
are these are kinds of the tough
questions in our space I think in a year
from now I'm going to be asking this why
are people still writing JavaScript to
do basic stuff why am I not living why
am I not just authoring with tags I mean
javascripts fine or in pick your
language dart whatever why am I not just
creating content fluidly just in a web
browser you know 3d multimedia content
the way I used to with some HTML tags I
mean Java scripts great canvas is great
god bless all these api's we wouldn't be
where we are without them but why am I
solving the same problems I was last
year so in a year from now if there
aren't tags for doing your 3d and your
other rich media I'm going to start
asking those questions Oh actually with
yours I mean some of the stuff with
polymer looks very promising I believe
you know there are actually some demos
where you can do that sort of thing
already and just sorted you mark up in
3d so it could very well be a thing yep
haha there's a very good question Dawn's
bosses in the room yeah exactly um well
I mean more or less with the web's where
it's going i'm very interested in how we
can build better applications on the web
WebGL is certainly awesome a joy it yet
you like get to the point already Thank
You Te'o um you know I'm more or less
interested in seeing where the web goes
how we're going to push it and serve
what the the new technologies are well I
mean I think web components are really
where the web is going to go because
developing with the DOM is pretty shitty
and you know we we need two more or less
keep pushing more of our apps to the web
I mean it's a great idea you know you
get the the collaboration you get the
mashups you get all these things and
that's really where applications should
be going i'm very interested in kind of
pushing you know where 3d sort of fits
into that space so that's why i'm
interested in so that's sufficient right
what i think it's interesting here is
that what we do now when we start
defining these ways to work with with
the web and WebGL is that we have a
great responsibility in doing so because
we will define how people will work it
and that means that we will define if
this will be a good thing if it will be
the next big thing or not but it's also
great responsibility it's what it is a
great responsibility but it's also a
great opportunity to do that so in a
year I think we need to ask ourselves
did we succeed and when it comes to the
whole organic ecosystem kind of view on
it as you said we need two ways to push
our apps through we need ways to connect
the publishers with the creators and
even if you don't know what you're doing
you should be able you should
because he's as you said even people
that have no idea what the web is or
haven't seen a browser before should be
able to get in touch with publishers if
they have a great content so I think
that's it's going to be a great big
challenge in a year from now I'm
probably just going to be wondering how
I can make like digital caffeine so I
don't have to go out and buy it anymore
that's it I think I'd be wondering
what's my spot on the waiting list for
the nexus of html5 all right so I think
we have time for one more question then
we go off to the raffle and for those of
you in the overflow rooms look at the
camera let's see over there you can come
in here for the raffle that make it
easier so we don't have to call out all
that so one more question who's got the
final question maybe your second
question
no getting up there yep okay go ahead um
you know none of us are actually on the
the chrome GPU team so there are some
people hanging around from the crumb GPU
team one might be hiding themselves in
the back so yeah Ken Lay ladies and
gentlemen for those who don't know this
is Kenneth Russell he's a the WebGL
working group chair and he works at
Google and he makes WebGL that works in
chrome which is awesome so Ken you're
going to give us a sneak peek at WebGL
too ok so first of all Tony gives me far
too much credit where's Brandon and
Vangelis ok so those guys back there
please stand up and wave so Bengal this
is brandon jones who did many of the
really super cool WebGL demos including
iOS rage in WebGL who is now a member of
our team thank you for joining and
Vangelis cook Eva's our boss please tell
him how great we are thank you very much
ok so um haha Tony gives me far too much
credit you know there's a joke about the
parrot who's the Chairman's like oh we
don't know what he does just they call
him chairman um it's funnier if you tell
the joke so WebGL to all right so Cronus
released a new version of OpenGL ES that
runs in your mobile phones and most
phones that are coming out now actually
have this standard it's a vast
improvement over the previous version
that's on previous generation mobile
devices and what WebGL is currently
based on um at Google and at Mozilla and
an apple we've been working on getting
the the baseline current WebGL really
robust
we had some bugs and chrome in chrome 29
you may remember WebGL was not it was
flaky on Windows that's a real problem
because you developers cannot deploy
your content in confidence knowing that
maybe it'll break on some browsers then
you fall back to something else canvas
something to d you have to redesign your
whole app because you can't rely on the
the new technology so we've been at
Google any way from working on
retrenching and really making sure that
that baseline is robust and we're almost
done with that big push so the next big
push will be finished the WebGL to spec
really get to work on the implementation
and I said this in a meet up early you
know a year ago or six months ago saying
wait six months and now I'm saying well
just wait another six months but we're
getting there and I think that the the
testing infrastructure will be much
better so that you can be guaranteed
that you're going to be able to deploy
the stuff immediately as soon as it's
turned on yeah I think it'll uh I'll
probably you know reach mid adulthood
and then need some coffee with milk and
I stay awake or something like that so
it'll do its own turbulent situations on
the GPU pretty sure pretty sure it'll be
doing its own turbulence simulations on
the GPU for its own milk and coffee yeah
that's what WebGL 3 is going to do